Williams rescued wounded teammates from
a mountain while under very heavy enemy
fire we will take you there live to the
White House when that happens in the
meantime Democrats are moving forward
with new rules for their impeachment
inquiry a full house vote is expected
tomorrow that is happening as top
Republican lawmakers attack how
Democrats want to move forward and how
Chairman Adam Schiff is running the
investigation they omit the process as a
sham and they're actually changing the
process for the worst they're making
Adam Schiff now the prosecutor the judge
and the jury and they're denying more
Republicans in the room and those who
are in the room only allowing one to ask
a question to interrupt us continually
to coach the witness to decide whether
or not what what we're gonna be able to
ask the witness I mean we don't even get
any witnesses at this point and
President Trump launched in a new phase
in his efforts to fight back against
impeachment he says unified Republicans
are now attacking the substance of the
allegations against him and we have the
oldest happening today partly Katie let
me go to you first that the Republicans
have pounded on process for a month
mm-hmm
that's actually a long time to sustain
an argument and now the Democrats are
changing do you think the Republicans
will be able to continue fighting on
process I think so just based on the
idea that this doesn't actually fall
into the real impeachment category once
again it's a step forward they're trying
to open up some of these hearings for
the American people to watch and see so
I think all of us will be happy to watch
some of this ourselves rather than
hearing from Adam Schiff or even
Republicans yeah regurgitated what they
think happened inside these hearings but
if they had the votes to do a real
impeachment inquiry and they thought it
was good politically they would do it
but they don't have the votes and polls
now when they're asked with nuanced
language and questions showed that the
majority of Americans including
independents and districts that Nancy
Pelosi wants to keep in 2020 in the
house aren't in favor of this and so I
think they're moving the process they've
set up this list of rules the
impeachment a document they released
yesterday simply lays out how it's going
to run but it actually doesn't mean much
in terms of changing the game here for
the White House now the White House is
you know preparing their hiring the
lawyers
they're hiring new communication staff
to try and get ahead of this but in
terms of the actual process of how this
is going to work it's not going away
she's a lab that I want to play this
roundup of media talking about the
damning testimony I could play that
bombshell impeachment testimony one of
the most damning witnesses yeah
Tuesday's explosive testimony shell
testimony tonight damning testimony on
Capitol Hill some fairly explosive news
about damning the testimony maybe after
that explosive testimony if it's very
damning to the president because
bombshell testimony before Congress
creating this damning portrait for the
president Jesse can I said the
Republicans had pounded on process for a
month but the Democrats are like every
day they have somebody else out there
with damning testimony well if it's this
big bombshell we should be able to see
the explosion but we can't see even like
a little glimmer of explosion because
it's all being done in the dark and the
Republicans are right to pound this
steel on process because it's corrupt
it's crooked and it's shady and it's
being run by Adam Schiff the chief
architect of the Russia hoax who's
already been caught witness tampering
and now he's witnessed coaching and he's
trying to find naked pictures of Trump
with a sicko so he's already been
slapped with an ethics complaint today
that guy's a joke and that's why they're
ripping it away from chef and giving it
to little Jerry Nadler instead to handle
but I think he's got a good argument on
the substance to I mean I've raised the
treaty up here a lot of times you can
ask Ukraine about corruption all you
want and Joe Biden is not above the law
Katie cited some great polls and I have
them right here because I know Juan
loves to talk about polls this is a CNN
report impeachment isn't popular in
Wisconsin and these five other key swing
states I don't need to read it but it's
all right here and I have another poll
here that say 59% don't want the
president impeached only 36% do that
Suffolk University USA day and 38% say
the phone call was impeachable 51% say
it's not an impeachable offense at rest
why why do you keep my face whole case
he just made I think it's bogus I mean
clear
let's run down the pollsters the
national polls are consistent in terms
of the increase in support for
impeachment and in some cases for
removal so you can focus on a few
districts here or there the national
story is pretty Clinton say yes I was
gonna say this I think Trump and his
folks to pick up on what Dana was saying
had been arguing process process process
for weeks even to the point of attacking
lieutenant colonel vent Minh and
defaming him and I think there's a way
that's so unpatriotic but the reason
they were arguing process is because the
facts are not on their side now the
process is in the Constitution Pelosi
the Speaker of the House has followed
the Constitution to the letter and now
they are moving into an open phase which
is what the president and his supporters
have asked for and they're still saying
oh that's not good enough
we don't like the open phase but here's
the thing the Republicans are trying to
work you the American people and say oh
don't buy it don't buy it
but again these polls are very clear
people say the transcript the transcript
that Trump said oh it's perfect the
perfect phone call now we know from
Lieutenant Colonel Pittman it wasn't
even the full transcript but they still
don't have what you would call the goods
on this president in terms of breaking
the law and being in a peaceful target
for them they're gonna start the process
but they don't have the same kind of
clarity that the people who are opposed
to Richard Nixon had all right when you
think of that I think a lot of that look
look what what the Dems are doing is
they're creating a train of opinions
that are all about the one thing the
transcript so they just find another guy
to say yeah you know what I was
concerned too so it's a train of concern
but a concern is not the same as
something that happens this is the story
of the Democrats they're concerned about
many things that never happen Trump's
instability Trump's insane Trump's of
big the stock market's gonna crash every
time they're worried about something
be confident it's never gonna happen
I wonder if there's a causal link
between the lackluster presidential
campaigns and the Democrats and the
impeachment hysteria could it be that
the Pietschmann
impeachment hysteria is draining their
party of all of their intellectual
energy I don't think the Dems can walk
and chew gum at the same time in an
effort to undo a previous election
they're gonna lose the next election
because they can't concentrate you know
they're like a co-worker right who does
everything possible to get out of the
job that they're doing that they end up
actually doing more work to get out of
the work they're causing more work for
themselves and so now and so right now
America we-we-we predicted this
Americans are kind of figuring this out
there they know this is a snow job they
know it's out of proportion to what
happened and I know and people make a
big deal about defaming vinda Minh but a
lot of the same people were saying the
same thing about Tulsi just weeks ago
not trionic one Greg Lee but you're
making a point Greg yet I think is so
wildly wrong it's President Trump who is
trying to rally Republicans and say hey
the cult has got to stand behind me do
everything calling after coal process
yes calling supporters a cult reflects
badly on you why I laugh at it it's all
about Trump it relates to that Trump
don't even back the Republican heart he
was back Trump call people a cult no
influence I think this is not just about
backing Trump I think the Republican
Party is in a different place you can't
crack the base one two things we have
heard that the White House event is
going to happen in just a minute or so
we're gonna keep talking here one thing
I think this does incumbency has there's
a lot of benefits to it right so you can
set up a contrast now you have the
president he's going to be in the East
Wing of the White House East Room at the
White House he's doing a Medal of Honor
ceremony he is going to be able to talk
about the fact that the Pentagon is set
to release we just got this breaking
the some video of the raid so there's
that so you can show and you can tell
people all the things that you're doing
when the contrast is on the hill
you have impeachment every day this is
the video Katie you can see the Pentagon
just released this everybody
this happened on late Saturday night
this is the compound where Baghdad II
was being held our boys was holed up
excuse me you can see our Special Forces
they're down at the bottom you can see
that very unusual for the Pentagon to
release this type of video but they must
have had Katie they must have believed
that they had all the intelligence that
they needed cleared out of the way so
they could babysit and show people what
happened yeah that's where I'll beg
daddy ran into a hole and decided to be
a coward and not fight back and I'm glad
that he's gone and the president
deserves credit for that absolutely and
you're a hundred percent right that this
does set up a contrast with White House
can argue that they are focused on
serious things like defending the
country from Isis defending the national
security of the country and trying to
push forward things on Capitol Hill I
was on Capitol Hill yesterday and there
are a number of House Democrats in
places like Iowa who are getting pushed
on issues like you haven't seen I have
to interrupt you there because we're
gonna be able to take a break we're
gonna be right back with the president
in the East Room we'll be right back